prayer of thanksgiving for all who serve
this community God our Heavenly Father
we give you thanks to all who serve in
local government administer the law and
preserve the peace those who serve this
community in safeguarding public public
health and ministering to the sick those
who provide for the welfare of their
young and care for the elderly and
infirm Lord as we give you thanks we
pray that you would help them in their
various duties and deepen within us all
the spirit of service to others as we
pray for this meeting Almighty God we
pray for all who exercise authority in
local government as we pray for this
meeting may all who serve on this
council be upright in character and wise
in judgment seeking first and foremost
the good of the community we ask that
all discussions and decisions may
strengthen all the work that is
currently being undertaken we are these
things through the love of Jesus Christ
our Lord amen thank you very much indeed
good see all and I'm dashing off not for
a romantic dinner with my wife that you
can pick up my daughter from the station
so I'm sorry I can't stay until you
asleep my captain egos I'd like to
congratulate congratulate you obviously
appointment in may I go as much in well
not sorry you're not the Archdeacon so
just congratulations are your new
appointment thank you very much me Kara
I just would thank you I just don't say
it I'm very sad to be leaving Raley
actually after almost 12 years and I
think very sad to be leaving you all you
may not be well you probably are sad
I'll be here for the next three meetings
so I'm not going to give up on you that
easily really but i may say a few words
on my last evening but it's been great
to be a part of this community I think
it's absolutely fantastic community and
I look forward to continuing association
I'm money moving one and a half miles
away on the other side of the 12
I have to say sadly no I wouldn't say
that back actually against trouble
refunded Lee if I say things like that
and so I will still have oversight of
Rayleigh which is not a threat it's just
a really good positive thing that I'll
still see you from time to time but
thank you very much early and I look
forward to you all very soon have a good
meeting tektronix pocket may go okay
members apologies for essence i had
counselor mrs. butcher counselor Mason
young Mason and encounter see Stanley
other any more poachers at all yes mr.
chairman and 12 apologies for a
counselor Nick Cooper thank you very
much thank you any other polish is a
tool to receive declarations of interest
number three medium term financial
strategy this is going to be from the
151 officer okay Thank You Jane
exclusion everyone and hopefully you've
all had a chance to digest the at the
time that was in front of you and I
would be presenting in front of you the
medium term financial plan for Rochford
district council from 2017-18 through to
20 21 22 I mean you will know that we've
in the midst of the most unprecedented
funding reductions funding constraints
has ever been in local government I
think they're safe to say since 2015-16
Rochford not just Rockford but what in
particular in terms of the numbers has
lost around 1.2 million of funding up to
now every year from something called the
rsg revenue support grant the amount of
money we got from central
by 2019-20 that would have ranked up to
1.8 millions worth of reductions about
eight seventeen eighteen percent of our
overall funding pot that's the sort of
reduction we've had to face you know
starting off last year and then right
through until nineteen twenty twenty
twenty-one and that's what this ntfs is
built upon the question aren't the thing
I'll stand here and say is we dumped all
the answers this is a forecast of what's
going to happen in the future there are
huge changes coming in terms of business
rates retention coming up in a few years
the government still quite doesn't quite
know how they're going to deal with that
yet and therefore we don't know what
impact that's going to have on our
finances yet so we can only give our
best estimation based on the knowledge
we've got now now what we've managed to
do so far is recognized that there is
going to be a financial problem in the
future that certainly came out last year
and it's been continuing continuing
trend this year for the next five years
and we look at our overall funding gap
it would be in the region of around 2.1
million that's the difference between
the amount of money we receive through
things like council tax and business
rates versus the amount of money we have
to spend on you know going up through
contractual inflation demographics
various other things I'll talk about in
a minute so that 2.1 million would be
our at the moment our best guess or
where we think we're going to be in five
years time but actually was there's
already a lot of work that's already
been in training a lot of works already
been done the year in now and identified
in the in the budget papers going
forward we've got about a million pounds
worth of savings and new income that's
been identified and that is going to
partly close that gap and we've got
sights on around 1.3 1.4 million of
further savings and income if we can
start to get some of the bigger investor
side projects that were coming through
the investment board sort of around the
summer to autumn of this year now if we
focus a little bit more on 17-18 I'm
very pleased to say we can present a
balanced budget you know that's one of
my roles is 151 we have to present a
balanced position and that has only been
through recognising certain pressures
that we can't get away from one of them
unfortunately is homelessness the
homelessness cost in 1617 has gone up
considerably and we're seeing new powers
and new regulations come into local
government and unfriendly burden in most
cases that will mean we need further
money in 70
to fund that we've also recognized that
our staffing levels are at critical in
certain areas after after several pieces
of work so there's been a recognition
that we're going to need to invest in
several key areas to both the frontline
services and also potentially generate
income as well that will hopefully
self-fund some of those roles in the
future we also know there are additional
pressures around things like contractual
inflation we can't get away from we know
there's demographic pressures and we've
also makes it a major decision to
increase the funding slightly on our
staff car passing one of the small areas
this year so overall that challenge
looks at like about an 850 sounds and
pound problem we had to find in 1718 I'm
pleased to say so far we've got savings
identified of about six hundred and
eighty nine thousand there in the report
and we have to recognize around a
thirty-two thousand pounds short for
wing funding which will be taken from
our general fund their general balance
and that is less actually a proposal to
increase council tax by one point nine
five percent next year which is around
8p per week per house per household
should I think that's the revenue side
as part of that that will fund part of
the capital program so the capital
program last year in Game four this year
will be around maintenance of our
existing assets not big new investment
yet so you are going to be talking about
new big castle programs at some points
but until they've gone to the investment
board we haven't included them yet here
in the budget at the moment the council
is on track to on its target of around
us by 2020 add a target of having
fifteen percent in its general balance
in its general fund this year the target
1718 is twelve percent which works out
around six weeks worth of funding Prada
see so basically we've got about six
weeks or at the money in the bank if
everything went completely wrong for the
earmark reserves however which much more
around our reserves that are targeted
for certain things we've continued with
the strategy that we started last year
around new homespun has been taken out
of our base funding and being used to
fund their transformation programmes now
in our infrastructure this does two
things one as you've seen you were seen
in the news in the autumn statement the
government drastic and reduce the amount
of new homes bonus it's about 2 300 k
for us this year it's back three or four
million over the five-year period
if we'd have had that built-in base
budget would have been in serious
trouble this year it would have been a
lot worse all thats done is potentially
curtailed how much we can put into our
transformation reserve in the next few
years that transformation reserve and
infrastructure fund ultimately is there
to prevent or to reduce the amount of
borrowing we're going to have to do on
some of these larger projects so you
know they let the more the neurosciences
reduce potentially the more we might
have to borrow we're not going to know
that until we get further into the
program that's about it i mean the
report is there obviously i'll answer as
many questions as i can i haven't had
any questions in advance so obviously
we'll we'll see how we go and that's it
thank you count the couple's be the
chisel very quiet I'd like to thank grop
learning and the team on along the work
they've done I'll also like to thank the
members for all the work they've done as
well I think we had the two away days
which are very successful I think the
way that the information was given to
members in a meaning in a way that
they'd understand was very very good
because it's not always good remember to
look at the Royal figures and try and
construe exactly what that means in its
implications to the council and to the
people of the District of Rochford
German part of the strategy is to raise
council tax remaining blessing as
mentioned the one point nine five
percent and of course this does equate
and I'm only repeating what he said 280
on average per household for AB and E
property which is not a great deal of
money it's interesting actually I was
taught today at County doing their
budget they're looking at a three
percent increase which is the rate
relating to social care they're not
raising their actual taste they could
have raised by cypress inn but having
said that it's interesting that many of
the counselors are sort of the opposite
benches that today with those were I see
it we're saying well we should have
raised council tax regularly over many
years because count
you've been holding back on doing that
and they'd have raised a hundred million
but hundred million a year is what 100
million that council tax payers will pay
in Essex so what I don't want to do is
to keep raising taxes and spending money
because Texas spend is wrong so it's
right that we make the things that we do
but of course we are under extreme
pressure from government and from other
sources and inflation now as well to
actually make sure that we cover
ourselves so this year the S one point
nine five percent will be looking into
the future to see how we can keep that
down but I think this counts as an
extremely innovative in the way that
it's taken itself forward with the
programs that we've got going forward
about transfer transforming itself of
its senior management about the number
of staff it now employs yes of course
you know we know they're going to be
pinch points but any business will know
that when they run their business they
look to those pinch points to make sure
that they're covering them so there is a
businesslike approach I think to what we
do there but there's also a human
approach because we're still giving
their services that we need and I think
again Rob mentioned meant that brought
many mentions the housing problems that
we've had and of course we put extra
money into that there are specific plans
for the future and how we can try and
bridge that gap as well with the help of
the sanctuary and others and their own
efforts to so I think overall this
council is running itself extremely well
I think there's very little you can
criticize on it yes of course you can do
things around the edges and I'm sure we
might hear about some of those tonight
but I think we have a very very good
budget and I commend him Thank You
counsel mr. Mason please thanks Alan and
I would also like to thank the finance
cream mr. Manning and pipette leah here
they've done a very great job in arms
laying all the sources very diverse
questions but it's been cooked by
members on soldier socks and my groups
and other groups so the reason you don't
have any questions tonight is because
you've done a great job so thank you
very much
support you've given me and I just want
to make it clear that because the mtss
going forward is mr. Manning says so I'm
certain we're not at all sure where
things are exactly going I find it very
difficult to give a rousing cheer for
all of that because I'm not I'm not
sufficiently confident around the
numbers either so I'm glad to see the
recommendations are largely around 17 18
which is of course where exactly where
we are with the budget and it makes it a
much easier to deal with I'd like
chairman if I may sloth used to have
recommendations 3.1 taken separately and
of course recommendation 3.6 these two
taken separately anyway because it
requires a recorded vote what I'd like
to do chairman this reflects upon a few
of the larger risks that I've seen to
the budget Authority there is a risk
because the job is actually stood up in
front so the LGA forum and he did say
that there was a cap on borrowing for
council housing projects now we don't
know what that means we don't know
whether it means it applies to those
councils which are still late sorry we
don't know that I can tell you the
property strategy project which many
members that just started participated
in or seek to answer that question
because otherwise that's why I reserve
the ntfs because we are projecting
forward some quite large following to be
able to take the spend and safe of
projects forward particularly investment
projects I've got to say chairman like
many other people around the country
probably at country as wealth and using
part of the new homes bonus is no way to
fund a clear budget it just is not the
right way of doing it and also
I go back far enough to with the new
homes bonus that it was originally put
forward for specific community benefits
around those areas that were subjected
if you like to greenbelt or other forms
of result in their area it was to
provide community facilities but it was
never that was never done practically by
any council in that way but at least we
had the sense to at least put it to
reserve necessar legs this 3.6 million
that we are ultimately going to lose
from it so far I've got to say to you is
because the Manning says going to
increase the borrowing that we that we
were projecting to undertake and that
actually you know puts me back to where
I started in talking about cat every
time this happens and our reserves are
diminished in our plans we need to
borrow more and that in itself may be a
problem many councils up and down the
country for a project reasons I'll
pouring from the Public Works and loans
board is part of the PSB are when I was
a student for the economics the PHP are
was a big issue I don't know if that
will come back but we've got to be
thoughtful the other thing we've got a
huge wrist on and leave them often here
I think Center a very thoughtful no
doubt this morning on the subject of the
homeless reduction bill and in there she
she put to us that there is a very real
likelihood that we're going to send even
more on that and it's not something
where we've made any form of earmark
reserved for so watch out I can see
other budgets being raided very quickly
during this year to support it I just
want to talk about some local matters to
fund the gap and I'm afraid some
criticism I don't agree with putting
third tier authorities under direct
pressure from the public to take over
all the
the public product albeit how to reduce
something you may not know is the local
government finance bill or otherwise
known as the business rates bill the
mailing referred to in a different way
is currently going through the
parliamentary process what you may not
have noticed is there's going to be a
disk renew new discretionary relief to
reduce the costs of local authorities
maintaining toilet now I've got to ask
will it be available to third tier
councils and those who rely on third
tier councils and considering taking on
the burden of toilets might like to bear
in mind that it may not come to you I
voted against the proposals around the
public toilet and that causes me to also
not support part of the recommendations
however I'm happy to agree i'm not happy
i'm prepared to agree yet are happy to a
1.9 1.95 percent council tax increase
because otherwise we're going to have to
drag a huge sums of money as our reserve
and i think we're going to need that
money to some the homeless reduction
bill so it's obviously with reluctance
of the leader set to increase council
tax but i see it that if we don't we
will have an even bigger issue around
that particular issue of homelessness or
we would have to cut services and that's
something again we'll even say he
doesn't want to see happen and order
life so that's where i stand chairman on
the budget on the NTFS output thank you
thank you transformation I can sir mr.
Eve please like you ready Jennifer I'd
like to add my
to the teams we've actually put this
weighty tome together and Sir Robert
aptly called it but I would like to draw
members attention to appendix 3 on page
three point hundred which is a note
listed against environmentally public
toilet options so they come back to this
again but it states of saving as 25,000
pounds now as the previously submitted
draft budget for members consideration
including capital budget figures that
are sent clean dropped from document we
are discussing tonight I'm puzzled as to
how we can include a saving against an
item that has no listed expenditure that
aside when we discussed the issue of the
public 22 full council I voted against
the proposal which put forward at that
time so I feel it be somewhat perverse
if i was to accept the current budget
which would in effect go against my
previous position therefore our mind is
not suitable to the current budget
recommendation 2.1 however as other
members have suggested i was reminded to
agree to the one point nine five percent
rise in council tax proposed so as to
not affect our ability to provide the
essential services any further than
already they are explained to be under
thank you thank you can freeze council
mr. Horsley other members and have and
will raise concerns about the budget
there I also hold I would however
withdraw members attention to the fees
and charges in the budget and the near
50 temple with facebook Park home sites
full does not agree with the statement
in paragraph nine point three on page
three point two one that changes in the
feet I have identified do not agree with
the policy it seemed that the site
owners
I've been subsidized by concerns tech
pays as the continued does not appear to
be right and I just like to point out
that and you'll always say Care Bear
sites currently have it noted that
caravans what your toes Park home sites
are septic okay thank you Thank You
councilman toy it was likely yes okay
thank you and I could I can answer that
question to a point and there we go show
em from what I understand the the 1617
fees were set based on estimates of the
work that would be needed on those sites
by officers now this fee is a it's a non
surplus non non profit fee as such it's
just officer time and cost and so since
Louise were started in herb Directorate
she ascends officers around to each of
these sites and worked out what the
actual cost is needed to do this work
yet to react to element so what you're
seeing here is a reduction but it's now
actually just a reflective of the true
cost that would it cost more rochford
whereas previously it was done a much
more of an estimate of the work that was
needed so that's the trip there change
for the price but for the EP Thank You
counsel look way please thank you madam
chairman I'd also like to thank NASA
section 151 officer and each team for
all the hard effort and work that they
put in to prepare the documents before
us and understand the exceeding the
extreme difficulty that he's been under
in trying to balance the budget for us
or give us the option before us to to to
balance the budget but I've got to just
take it a little bit broader in some
respects because these these difficult
decisions aren't being made in isolation
these the hid the position that air
Council finds it in itself in and other
councils find themselves in East you two
decisions being made
Westminster and I find it exceedingly
disappointing that we have a government
that seems to want to punish its own
people through lack of funding to
services at local government level and
we are fortunate that we do not have the
responsibility of social care in this
council because that is a great problem
for many councils around this country
and I are finally exceedingly
disappointment that disappointing that
they can't find appropriate funding for
their own people when they are still
being able to expend vast sums of money
in foreign aid and other vanity projects
we seem to be not spits for purpose
thank you thank you can't really account
for black please I've come in about
seven to eight here so it may sound a
bit trite but yes thank you sir the
world of you and your clothing from the
budget it is understood even though like
many other members I'm not happy with
the outcome it's not a very palatable
Valentine's Day meal is it really and I
will probably answer I think on the
first started basically a nice kick off
the vote of the budget i will probably
wouldn t support the increase in council
tax although there's no whip in our
group as always so what my colleagues
will do is up to them yes the refuse of
seems bleak I don't think it's down to
the vanity projects or the vast amounts
of money be expecting elsewhere we
managed to spend vast amounts of money
even vast amounts of money are bailing
out the banks of our back it's just we
have a government were dancing to
understand but it's sitting austerity
and even worse than that could have to
be trusted to keep its word i think so
things a lot of new homes bonus used to
be evaporating like a poorly designed
bungalow it's it's just
if load is pressing in the words of ink
the Corporal places I think they all
doomed it gets bleaker and bleaker year
by year and our home bull burglars going
to this budget will reap rewards and
we'll try the way out of it but I don't
think this government at the moment if
it's realizing the state of things
certainly isn't it'll be 350 million Lee
a week for the NHS or / social care
anything else but we need to find more
money for those services because it is
to coordinate closely desire people
thank you very much Thank You counsel
back counsel mr. hi please thank you
madam chairman and as we assume
counselor Carl azuz one second budget of
the day and either further budget to
analyse the SFO authority so if i'll be
on budget LT by the end of the week i'll
come back to the this one is budget
later actually very briefly however I do
have published this budget some which
have already been raised by other
members I do understand the current
problems faced by the council but it is
not this does not take away the fact
that diminish the administration
supports the cuts on it imposed by the
Conservative government and if you have
actually this morning think leads which
were interesting the counselor what way
ray's disco straight on consumer then it
was surprising about how many
conservative members this morning also
were rather despairing of the
Conservative government not listening to
local councils and I just hope that we
continue to push this council continue
to push for assistance where we need it
and I'm shortly after cutting mobile
will do that and does do that we've got
to the detailed budget I was interested
to know the final bullet points in
paragraph 7.1 on page three point five
and i would say regulars actually expect
as a minimum services to be at least
maintained or the previous level but
what they are seeing and have seen over
the last few years is a listening and
removal of those services for they pay
up when council sex unless i see from
regiment all the time they are always
complain about we've seen
and this provision of service we
precisely darkness with the papers were
a few years ago and we know that I might
understand the reasons right because we
being cut that he's not recognized that
we're maintaining services five
residents in a specific area with regard
to monitoring of air quality this budget
does not go far enough even though
requests be made to explain monetary
into areas other than the very limited
testing done at present this has not
been taken on board by the
administration every air pollution is
responsible for 15,000 premature deaths
in the UK each year this is referring to
the BBC to inject November 2016 if you
want a source for that and this council
has a responsibility to our residents
and visitors that they should not be
unduly harmed by pollutants and we
believe the in relatively cheaply
measure where we have this problem we
know ready is one already but we only
measure a very few areas in the district
and seem silly about some very congested
areas such as roars line and the center
of hopefully and even that a lot of the
pr2 routes around the area such as going
through I daresay hullbridge I will not
be supporting the budget but i'm
currently mind to support the one point
nine five percent increase as I cannot
see how else existing services continue
to be supportive I'll just fishin on one
point which is was raised favorite
people on section 151 officer and it's a
very small amount it's probably in
significant in terms of the budgets but
I think on the matter of policy in
principle it needs to be raised which
was about the funding of car parking for
staff this is a reason because of the
change in federal government policy over
faction of salary sacrifice scheme
perhaps in future budgets I think we
should look at may be assisting the
lower functioning themselves and other I
think the top six extensive staff should
bear the costs of their parking and the
detect there now pay on it not being
that should be looked at me bit more
detail lips you thank you I high
Council's mystery
Thank You chairman clearly when it comes
to budget we can't agree about
everything but I think through the
discussion we've had this evening we've
clearly identified and we've known no
uncertain terms that have been problems
about money and certain balance budgets
for quite some time but I would like to
thank all members for the pragmatic
approach that have taken towards this
budget setting process this year I think
that we've has many constructive
discussions and then I say a reasonable
amount of collaboration the report
that's in front of as 133 pages in total
is the loss of work it's not something
that is produced quickly it's rob
leading with Matt and of course all the
80s there's a lot of work on I'm gone
into this budget and it's been clearly
recognized by what the members are so
tonight so I felt it was still
appropriate for me to add my thanks for
the work that's been done I think we've
got a valid viable budget which can
allow us to go forward and give us some
scope and flexibility for dealing with
some of the innovative and bigger
projects that are coming forward in the
next year year or so so I'm quite happy
to support this project and I do
encourage members to do so offer Thank
you Thank You counsel sit as there are
no more questions before we go through
the recommendations of each one I need a
move and a second displease to thank you
count the cut law and count
right members we will take each one each
recommendation one at a time 2.1 the net
revenue budget requirement be set at 9.8
59 million for 2017-18 is that do all
the show of hands those in favor please
and those against please
alright
that is carried members 2014 to point to
the capital program 2017-18 is that
agreed members or join a show hands
harmful of grief show hands please
members is that erm is for sorry 2.24
please that's agreed Thank You members
2.3 section flight 151 officer we
authorized to adjust capital project
budget in 2017-18 is that agreed members
or do you want to agreed 2.4 if you
notice that the supposed council tax
requirements for the council's own
purposes for 2017 is that agreed members
2.5 the draft equivalent vandy tax base
for the purpose of determining the
council tax charge is that agreed
members 2.6 I understand it has to be
approved by recorded vote this is the
increase in lots of district council
types lights on your place councilor
black
councillor Carter counselor mrs. Castle
canceller cut more canceller Dre
counselor esky can please cancel ooh
this is good in Chancellor Griffin
counselor Hazelwood Chancellor hook way
counselor mrs. hoy canceller hoy cancels
issues can float Jana cancel Lucas kill
calculus is lovely cancel Christine make
them cancer John Mason cancel Alaric
cancel alone
cancel the lighting console newport
cancel oroton cancel mrs. Rowe can't
Lucy Shaw cancellous less for counselor
sparing cancer steptoe canceller ward
councillor web can't lose his Western or
cancel a Williams and cancer Wilson
unanimous magnanimous thank you very
much 2.7 schedule of fees and charges
for 2017-18 be a fruit if it agrees
members we know she's 95 stage please
Thank you Thank Stanford 2.8 Jennifer
Allen's be set at one point 182 million
as access of eight to twenty seventeen
degrees members 2.9 the earmarks
reserves be set as for the table in
Section thirteen seventeen is a degreed
members to point chain the 2016-17 17 18
potential indicators and limits together
with updated limits be noted is that
agreed members to 11 statement on the
robustness of the estimates and reserves
be noted is that agreed members noted to
point 12 the summary of the equality
impact assessment as set out in section
11 of this report be noted no key
members thank you and that's it
it's nearly quarter past eight and
that's the end of the meeting
councillors thank you very very much for
your time this evening
[Music]
you
you